So before we start getting coded,
let's take a second to
draft up our page designs.
There are a ton of good mock-up and
wireframing applications, that you can
download and use to design webpages, but
for me, pencil and
paper is perfect for the first draft.
So the first question
that comes to mind is,
how many types of pages
this app will have.
So when the user lands
on the root of my site,
they should see a list of all
the restaurants stored in my database.
>From here, they can click on a specific
restaurant that will show the menu for
that restaurant.
I also want them to be able to
add new restaurants, and edit or
delete existing
restaurants from the list.
On a specific menu page, the user can
view the menu for each restaurant.
Similarly, they will have
the option to add, edit, and
delete menu items from a specific menu.
So it looks like we need to create eight
different webpages for our web app.
I will go ahead and
specify what I want the URL for
each webpage to look like as well.
Draw markup pages for
these eight URLs using pencil and
paper or
your own favorite markup application.
It doesn't have to be anything fancy,
just a sketch to communicate how
you want your webpages to look.
Share you markups,
get feedback from a friend or
colleague, and then continue on
to the next step of our project.